[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dormer Johnson right here please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Charlie Tango is here with you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god right in front of you please
[Music]
first one was probably
the shoulder fella right here turn your
body to the left
right here this
the whole picture
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a great dress
and the dates not bad
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay you're not bad guys could you come
down a tiny bit and then face me there
we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ha
[Music]
turn your body this way you fight there
you go right here Eloise Eloise down the
line at least one more man one more this
way
Eloise right there right in front of me
there you go and looking straight ahead
right here
[Music]
[Music]
one more time when we remark straight
head right here Hold'em we're right in
front of you please right there there
you go right here to your left to your
left one more time on your left Eric on
your left right there please right there
perfect looking straight ahead right in
front of you please Marsha over the
shoulder left
Marsha facing straight Marsh I'm
disheartened oh yeah barn March on the
front please cross the front right there
Francis Francis the front tooth right
there
Rance this right here one more time from
the frightened Francis were ready wait
wait wait
right here Robin
and right over here put down a step or
two there you go
[Music]
you